what hey we're tomorrow right together
hi i'm sumi hi i'm yong joon hi i'm bum
gu
hey this is taehyun hi guys this is
yunikai
and we're with buzzfeed to answer 30
questions
in three minutes let's see who can give
the fastest
answer
[Music]
how would you describe tomorrow together
in three worlds okay tomorrow
bye together
you could go anywhere in the world right
now where would you go i want to go usa
la la hawa
if you could only listen to one tomorrow
write together song for the rest of your
life which will it be i would choose to
your spouse name
zero my one love song yeah what's your
favorite hair color black black white
black who's your passion and inspiration
i would choose me
because some fashion king so you're like
what's your biggest fear death sorry of
course
i agree with that ghost ghost
that's one thing you've always wanted to
do but i haven't done that skydiving
boxing skydiving skydive if you could
time travel
which decades would you visit yeah
middle school
or elementary school sing and hold day
notes for three seconds
tomorrow what's one food you wouldn't
ever want to give up ramen ramen ramen
ramen ramen ramen ice cream what's a
song that always puts you
in a good mood i wish you snow ruth me
too i wish tomorrow my together
accomplishment
are you most proud of ah when we have a
concert at wingochango
what's your most used emotion heart
emoji who's the last person you call
maybe hyunikai my sister my mom my mom
what time did you go
to bed last night twelve two
who would play you in a movie about your
life maybe
tom hardy or dicaprio
christian what's your phone screen
wallpaper
ocean ocean me too what's your life
motto
enjoy enjoy do your best
if you are stranded on an island and
could only bring three things video
what would they be i'll choose bear
grease oh yeah
all right bear grease oh my god and if
you have to bring one person
i'll just hang on no i don't want to i
will choose bungie
what's something that most people don't
know about you i'm an angel
actually i'm a hot guy
[Laughter]
favorite clothing item i would choose
hoodie shirt
hoodie what's another job that you
think you'd be good at reporting
because i love talking to someone
what's the first thing you think when
you wake up in the morning
oh my god i'm late
why me where do you see tomorrow by
together in 10 years from now
they're definitely hills yeah
[Applause]
ariana grande
i love you guys can you give us three
different poses in the next second three
two one three two one
three two one wow that was really
intense it was fun to see everyone's
instant reactions though
we love you moana we love you moana
thank you for your support always
do your best don't be afraid and don't
be upset
thank you buzzfeed be sure to check out
our second studio album
and title track zero by one love song
and i love you bye
you